allez on termine ce journal avec un peu
de poésie la poésie des clowns dont
l'humour agit comme un antidépresseur
dans la période actuelle
la petite fabrique du cirque compagnie
inhérente de beaulieu-lès-loches
concours au célèbre nikon film festival
festival international de courts
métrages on en parle avec notre invité
ce soir en soir julien gerbier bonsoir
on va parler de ce court métrage dans un
instant mais d'abord l'actualité des
festivals qui s'annulent les uns après
les autres les artistes qui occupent les
théâtres comme celui de tours pour
protester contre le confinement de la
culture et votre chapiteau de cirque
itinérant qui est cloué au sol
bref comment vous faites face comme on
peut on tient la barre on travaille avec
les équipes d' instits avec qui on a
prévu des des projets on tient au
courant les uns les autres ou des
projets annulés pour certains d'autres
ouais orthez annulé on essaye de ne pas
aller jusque là dans la mesure du
possible de reporter le plus qu'on peut
avec les équipes de voir comment dans le
calendrier ça peut aller
voilà on fait face ont fait face avec
les instits puisque votre activité c'est
de transporter ce chapiteau près les
écoles pour des ateliers cirque elle que
les enfants on va y revenir
alors je le disais votre film concourt
pour le nikon film festival
alors on tue suspense tout de suite vous
n'êtes pas qualifié pour la finale et
vous êtes toujours en lice pour le prix
du public c'est ça c'est ça on peut
voter jusqu'au 11 avril sur le site
festival nikon point fr on va tout de
suite découvrir un extrait de votre
court-métrage
[Musique]
voilà pour cet extrait ça dure un peu
plus de deux minutes pour quelles
raisons d'abord vous êtes lancés dans
cette aventure nord de notre forme de
création en attendant des jours
meilleurs
ouais c'est exactement ça c'est le fruit
d'une rencontre avec florent gauthier
qui est le réalisateur avec qui on a
profité entre guillemets du confinement
pour réaliser le teaser du spectacle
c'est à dire que l'extrait qu'on a vu
c'est pas du tout le spectacle de commun
accord
ça c'est je suis de travers et on l'a le
teaser va peut-être et du coup après
l'expérience du travail avec florent il
nous a proposé de participer au festival
nikon puisque lui participe tous les ans
avait saisi l'occasion parce que c'est
ça c'est un autre travail pour nous nous
on a l'habitude entre guillemets du
travail au plateau sur la piste dans la
rue où on endosse nos personnages on les
fait vivre
on a le temps de se plonger dedans et
c'est face à une caméra c'est pas du
tout le même travail
il ya un plan en quatre secondes huit
secondes on déplace la caméra on change
les lumières c'est pour nous comédiens
c'est un tout autre boulot et c'est pour
ça qu'on on a bien volontiers accepté sa
proposition
alors vous êtes topette
vincent siro votre votre sirote sirote
par d'or n'y a pas mal qui vous
accompagnent ces maestros vous incarner
deux personnages ovi bancal au propre
comme au figuré
c'est ça ouais c'est ça c'est un duo
qu'on a créé tous les deux vincent et
musiciens vraiment la base je suis clown
mois plus tôt et l'idée c'était de mixer
noar ensemble et du coup c'est dégagé
les figures classiques du duo de clowns
à un blanc un rouge et est là l'idée
d'en pour le pour le festival nikon
c'était de faire revivre ces personnages
là dans une autre atmosphère dans un
autre lieu
et de voir comment ils allaient s'en
sortir de cette heure a lancé ces deux
personnages dernière question les
retrouve dans vos spectacles itinérants
et sans vous rencontre avec les enfants
dans les écoles où vous restez deux à
trois semaines
le cirque comme outil pédagogique qui
apporte île aux enfants tous moi je suis
instit à la base donc le travail avec
les gamins je le connais j'aime ça c'est
un c'est un super moyen c'est un super
médias le cirque c'est à la fois une
activité physique donc il ya tout ce
développement là pour les enfants la
prise de risque la recherche de
l'équilibré etc etc
et puis il ya le travail aussi un peu
théâtral c'est à dire qu'à un moment
faut aller en piste
faut se mettre en représentation faut
accepter le regard des autres donc c'est
très intéressant pour la cohésion du
groupe accepté les remarques laisser la
place aux arts aux autres c'est un très
très bel outil
merci beaucoup julien husser gerbier de
la petite fabrique du cirque on rappelle
qu on peut voter pour votre
court-métrage sur festival nikon point
fr pour le le prix du public merci
beaucoup merci à vous